Bud Light parent company stock
downgraded by HSBC emit branding crisis
huge sales drop this is the Fox Business
story HSBC downgraded Anheuser Bush and
Bev stock to hold the signing a crisis
following Bud light's marketing campaign
with uh transgender activist Dylan
Mulvaney HSBC Carlos Laboy expressed
concerns about the Brand's response the
and the significant drop in sales
stating that the way this Bud Light
crisis came about raises many questions
sales about land in the U.S plummeted
reaching one percent of the company's
Global volume in the uh in sales uh
stating uh uh in the first three weeks
of April retail sales store sales of Bud
Light also experienced a sharp decline
of 21.4 compared to the previous year in
contrast Coors Light and Miller Lite saw
sales increase by almost 21 percent
exactly same
same percentage Laboy questioned the
decision making and risk assessment of
Abi's leadership that's Anheuser-Busch
asking why did its U.S leadership
underestimate the risk of pushback given
the recent experience of other firms is
a b hiring the best people to grow the
brands uh grow the brands engage risk
that's the question so do you think
America how we are we forgive we move on
they're going to do a bad wise or
they're going to do a commercial the
frogs are going to make a comeback and
we're going to be like you know what man
I'm reminiscing them yeah I want to have
all my life
do you think we're forgiven or do you
think this is going to be something
that's going to be around for a while
let's suppose McKenzie I Gotta Throw
That one in there going Way Way Back
that's a great question I've tried to
think about this and I think over the
next year it's going to be a big deal
uh I I think over the long run as far as
the overall parent company I don't know
if it'll make that big of a difference
because they have so many other brands
so many people don't even realize you
know people think that if they're you
know go from Bud Light over to XYZ it
might not be cooler but something else
that they're doing damage but they don't
realize they're just going from one of
their products to another of their
products I I don't know that it'll have
long-term consequences but uh I could be
wrong I hope I'm wrong yeah I think if
you look at it as an individual brand or
if you look at it in the company you
figure it as an individual brand yeah
this is what what matters now is what
the competitors do with the opportunity
because now that now there's weakness
now there's there's something for the
taking and it all depends on how the
competitors responds and I don't think
the response isn't is in a week or a
month I think as you said the response
is what happens in in the next year but
I think Patrick's right I think
Americans are very forgiving so they're
forgiving until you break and I I don't
think that I don't think that's broken I
think people tend to forget I mean I
think Pat's absolutely right they're one
good commercial away and about six to 12
months away people being like ah you
know what those Bud Light guys we're
drinking again yeah but at the same time
like the the the there was two
commercials that Dylan Mulvaney did that
people that pissed people off number one
was the March Madness commercial where
basically
he she it thee them whatever he is
couldn't Define what March Madness was
he's like I think it's something about
it was just so obnoxious and the second
one that pissed people off was the one
in the bathtub and
and to rand's credit about his
capitalizing Coors Light did a
commercial of a dude just kind of
sitting back in his bathtub yeah exactly
how many dudes are just taking baths and
they called it the best seat in the
house and he's watching a game kind of
like a macho man watching a basketball
game you know in his bath uh versus
juxtaposed that with
her oh doing her little dance in the
bathtub but Bud Light has been some of
the made some of the greatest
commercials of all time between the
what's up yeah
actually I'm glad I don't have my
glasses I completely missed the mark on
this I'm gonna prove this well we know
who approved it it was that one lady
basically saying listen for forever Bud
Light was this sort of fratty bro type
of brand and we tried to move away from
that but it's like that's your Market
dudes who drink beer yeah not
she females that that during I could
argue I could argue the other side too
because you know uh if if I have it if
I'm going out let's say like as an
example when you came down to Medellin I
think I was drinking old Fashions and I
had yes I love old Fashions drink over
the last five years or but now I was
turned on I don't even know how to uh um
Don Julio Don Julio 70 and man that is
good and and now I drink that when I go
out and the old Fashions are just part
of History so maybe maybe people that go
from Bud Light to Coors Light will never
ever go back and they have to rely on
the the younger people that are coming
into drinking age going to Bud Light and
that will definitely take some time but
it'll be very interesting to see how
this plays out Adam's more of a rose guy
he likes desserts
hey if you're buying I'm drinking that's
the kind of guy these are these are just
bad American bears but for Branding I
American America is forgiving but I
think that this one's gonna fling for a
little bit because the longer this trans
thing and what's going on the election
is there I think that doesn't help them
on their effort to bounce back but
there's so much Heritage and so much
brand Equity as it's called with
Budweiser as a whole I think there's an
opportunity for them to come back but I
do not think that this dialogue and all
this controversy and trans is going to
help it go away anytime soon because you
have to remember you need the
controversy to go away and the longer
the controversy is gone the longer you
know remember once upon a time every you
know female football fan in America was
upset with Brett Favre because he was
sending images and stuff and everybody
was disappointed in me wasn't our hero
anymore but the longer it was since that
and his wife had breast cancer and he
had a divorce on her there is a real
Schism that was there but guess what if
people have get on with that longer the
controversy is away from you and the
more you just show who you are after
saying you wouldn't exchange a text with
Brett Favre today like you're over it no
I will
uh I will crazy images
Charles Barkley who was talking to Ernie
about it and he said I just got one
thing to say Brett if you're gonna do
that the one rule is is got to be
ginormous can Charles Barkley said that
it is shaking his head you know so I I
think the longer I think the trans
controversy is kind of Charles you know
kind of normalize a little bit Yeah and
then that will be away from the brand
and the brand can make a comeback
it's a bonehead move how would you feel
right now going to Powerball going to a
party and holding a bad life yes so this
is what I was gonna say well
I mean right now today you're at a party
you're at a pub you're at a nightclub
and somebody hands you a free bad light
now is it in a can or is it I mean
[Music]
you're never getting fist fights when
they're drinking cans yeah this is this
is this is the serious thing this is a
very good point
when you were drinking Bud Light in a
can at the bar the other day tell us
what happened hang on I'll give you a
real world example yesterday take my
daughter we go
down see Miami Marlins you know
and we got standard Stadium food and I
noticed that right there it was just
like the pictures you see on social
media that I was thinking maybe they're
making it up they took the picture of
the you know the the Bud Light counter
nobody's standing there maybe they took
that when it just opened and nobody was
there it was legit nobody was standing
there they were over there getting
Yingling and other beers that were there
but that little Bud Light stand that
poor person was just sitting there a
little blue shirt and they weren't
buying ran hit a nail on the head no
dude wants to be at a stadium in a Bud
Light line while he's trying to get
something else how many guys were Adidas
who was Adidas
you wear Adidas yes okay you know Addie
Adidas ADI Adolf yeah Founder's name was
adol yeah and you know what Adidas is
linked to what you're not easy this is
linked to it I didn't know if you're
gonna tell Nazism I didn't know that's
what it's like I thought it was two
brothers one of them was well it's
linked to that when you go to to the
dark history of Adidas right and then if
same goes with Volkswagen as a young man
yeah but the point is I mean if you were
Adidas today and if you were Volkswagen
today Demi's eventually going to drink
Bud Light okay the history tells us and
that's why I'm asking how long but how
long is you know could be you know he
said one year I don't know I don't know
one to five years and and by the way the
way you do it is the following here's
what you have to do it here's what you
have to do you have to fire the CEO
immediately because you have to show
everything Rises and falls on leadership
this happened under his watch I agree
you fired a CEO you fired a CMO you
fired a marketing department you find a
replacement immediately then you make a
statement saying we have to go to a
different direction and here's what
we're doing we brought XYZ from this
place his background's got to be
military his background because you know
the currency used to be a CIA agent you
got to bring a different kind of a guy
that comes in and maybe you're going to
say hey I got this guy he's more boom
here's the New Vision this is where
we're going to be going on the rest of
history people move on so this happened
but for now they're gonna take a hit you
know when you look at the stock market
curve and you look at the hardware up up
and then you see covert yeah and then
you see it goes up again this is covered
this is uh bad lights Black Swan but if
you zoom out in 100 years you'll
eventually so what you're saying is if
in a week
you get an email okay them asking you a
question saying hey we would like to
sponsor your podcast would you take it a
hundred thousand dollars per month I'm
not a chance about a hundred thousand
per month not for sale a million in
episodes not for sale we will let you be
the CMO to Linda the new CEO of Twitter
would you take it not for sale so you're
not going to take anything from Bud
Light right now no but you will a year
from now
and you were Adidas why don't you do it
I would need to see what I would need to
see what they did lifetime supply of
Adidas shoes with Bud Light and a brand
spanking Volkswagen parked outside zero
to seven in ten seconds I'm just I'm
just thinking about
I'm thinking of a practical I'm thinking
of a practical question also you know
can you imagine a guy can you imagine
any guy walking up to any bartender in
any club can you imagine how he would
order the bad light now it's like
just Whispering it out there well I
won't whisper this I'll make a public
announcement to the CMO Bud Light if you
want to pay me double what you paid
Dylan Mulvaney
[__] right now
let's go and also value 10 minutes
looking for Value time is also looking
for a headline sponsor and uh they are
in talks with three uses there is first
space for a fourth now because Gold
light it's not a high-end you know there
might be if this was Hennessy maybe
there's people that would defend
Hennessy that's a high-end beverage but
Bud Light is not a high in beverage to
make Bud Light if you feed a gallon of
water to a horse and put a bucket under
the horse right that's how you make a
butt line it's a simple filtering
process
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you